it's just about December and that means
one more batch of free games for Xbox
Live Gold members this year think of it
like a holiday present for Microsoft
fans if you want to know what you'll be
unwrapping this month I've got you
covered
hopefully there's a little something for
everybody first up Xbox one owners can
unwrap Warhammer end-times vermintide if
you think Warhammer is just a strategic
tabletop game you'll be pleasantly
surprised with this one think left for
dead but swap the zombies for war
hammers rat people but Skaven each hero
has different skills so working together
with your friends is the only way to
stem the littoral vermin tide that'll be
available all month long if you prefer
something a bit more uplifting Xbox one
is also getting back to the future the
game 30th anniversary edition this
version includes all five episodes of
tell tales adventure Plus special
behind-the-scenes features just like
you'd expect from a telltale game your
choices affect the outcome of Marty
McFly's story you can go back in time
from December 16th through January 15th
on the 360 side you can feel the rhythm
with child of Eden if it reminds you of
rez that's cool since it comes from the
same creator as you might expect you can
lock onto targets fire at various
objects and set off all sorts of sound
effects that augment the music in each
stage child of Eden will be available
from December 1st through the 15th and
finally the 360 is also getting marlow
briggs and the mask of death marlow
comes back from the dead to fight his
way to his girlfriend using a ton of
different weapons you can start the
adventure from December 16th through
December 31st and thanks to Mac words
compatibility both this and child of
Eden can be played on Xbox one as well
and those are your free games with gold
for December 2017 remember that you can
always check out gameplay clips and
reviews for these titles over at
GameSpot and if you want to keep up with
all of our top stories you can grab the
official game spot now app on iOS and
Android
[Music]